today we're gonna talk about the nine
things that your skin can tell you about
your liver so let's go to number one
yellow skin that's jaundice that is a
liver problem if your skin is slightly
orange that could also be jaundice or it
could be that you're drinking way too
much carrot juice I remember in my late
20s I was consuming a mass amount of
carrot juice and I literally turned
orange so that was just a pigment coming
from the carrots that's not a liver
problem alright number two read palms
it's called palmar erythema and that's
just a sign that there's something wrong
with your liver
number three spider veins in the upper
part of your body or spider angioma
which is a dilated blood vessel that is
coming from the liver your liver is not
able to break down the estrogen so it's
an estrogen dominant problem you'll see
this after pregnancy or if someone's
taking estrogen replacement therapy
number four white growths on your
eyelids that is a cholesterol build-up
usually the person's triglycerides are
high they have low HDL that's the good
cholesterol but it's actually not really
good or bad but because the liver
controls cholesterol having a liver
problem can create that buildup number
five
purple flat bumps on your skin it's
called Lichen planus that is an
indication that there's a liver problem
next one number six there's little
purple or red spots on the skin it could
be in the lower legs or it can be on the
arms it's called ecchymosis number
seven white scaly plaques on your scalp
another term for that is dandruff and
that is a liver problem and what's
creating that symptom is a lack of
vitamin b2 and b6
a lot of the B vitamins are in the liver
and when there's liver damage and you
cannot utilize those vitamins properly
and there's a whole series of skin
problems that go along with a vitamin b2
deficiency anywhere from a basic
dermatitis all the way to pellagra which
is an advanced skin problem but junk
food will not just destroy the liver but
create massive deficiencies especially
with the B vitamins and that leads to
all sorts of issues with your
skin number eight chicken skin where you
see those little red bumps on your hair
follicles
it's called hyper keratosis that is a
problem with the liver and the liver is
supposed to store vitamin A because it's
a fat soluble vitamin as well as vitamin
E and when these two vitamins become
deficient you can start developing these
little bumps on your hair follicles
alright number eight darker pigment on
your knuckles okay and your hands
there's a liver problem which affects
your b12 now that you know that the next
question is what are you going to start
doing or eating for the liver for that
answer I put this video up right here
check it out